when you sit down to write a story do
you begin outlining
every single script
has been different like um
the last one i just did um
rosa perla i did outline this
uh um i have
uh the last one i just did is uh called
um only the dead leave early only the
dead leave early
i didn't outline at all you know i
actually
um i just started with it
with an image and then locked myself up
locked myself in a um
car uh i would drive
my wife to work and then i would sit in
the car
because that would force me not to look
at my phone and i would write for a
couple hours
and then that way i could talk things
out so if you're walking by and seeing
this guy talking
to himself in a car he's either like
going crazy or something but it
i felt that was right for that
particular script that and made me
do it every day something that made me
do it the another script
prior to um was a different process
so it's just changes i think that might
be
uh intentional because i want to try
different ways
but what kind of helped me was maybe
hearing jeff nichols talk about
movie days and that gave me a structure
like uh
movie day one two three four five six
seven if the
if the movie took place in seven days
that gave me like a
like a feel of what's going to happen
during that time with these characters
so um i think it depends
for each one but i think the outline
does help sometimes i know the ending
prior to
so i'll work backwards and if i ever get
stuck i'll jump
jump different places and jump different
scenes
um i usually have an image to start out
with
and then something to end with and i'll
build and
eliminate and and form up the story
there
but i try to i try to leave with the
characters
and once i have a solid grip and
understanding
the characters sort of let them go in
the story yeah
what was the image for all roads to
perrla
wow you know at first
it was a plastic bag plastic um
bag hanging in a tree and near a uh um
a nodding donkey uh just going back and
forth
and the sound of the chain that just
tick tick ticks
and then um it was just the landscape
and then uh
i remember i did a mood reel six years
ago
showing what type of film i i would want
i would cut that piece together
and i put put that piece with daniel
johnson's song
devil's deviltown and it's funny to see
that mood reel
six years ago and then the trailer now
it's
how how close it is it's kind of kind of
cool
that that the world still maintained
throughout through through the process
so
um you know i like that but the image
was
uh you know this plastic bag
um that just was stuck in a tree
you